he came he screamed he soiled his
diapers then he left
it's a sad day for America Keith
Olbermann says goodbye I am retiring
from political commentary in all media
venues thank you for all the kind words
and all the support I don't recall
anyone giving kind words or support we
just observed his Tantrums which
embarrassed those who indulged him no
matter he's broken more roadkill from
the Trump reign but we must admit all of
these casualties from Keith to Kathy
Griffin to that Will and Grace has been
what's-her-face anyway they're all
self-inflicted Trump isn't breaking them
they're breaking themselves as they Fred
over the Trump apocalypse they go home
to more comfort than ever spending more
money on therapists than their
grandparents spent on rent so many
people unnerved by Trump Trump are yet
oblivious to the real-world problems
meanwhile Trump tweets that a fake news
trophy be given to the network that
distorts coverage of your favorite
president which he adds in parentheses
me and there it is in one winking joke
the reason why all be and is ill corso
down trump's having fun and they're not
the warfare is finally reversed that one
word me encapsulate s' the weapon in two
letters which stabs into the heart of
the modern humorless liberal they used
to have fun not anymore
now they're old and frail forced into
retirement by their own bitterness who
knew that laughter would kill the left
and so a fond looked back cue the somber
music
[Music]
who are beholden to scum Russian scum
you must atone not merely because the
man you support is a pagan and you must
now do what is right
permitting Donald Trump to assume the
office of president reduces the chance
that we will have any future elections
have fun storming the castle my work
here is done
very sad in lieu of flowers please send
donations to the research for the
Prevention of a rational outrage Jesse
have we is he really gone or when will
he be back I didn't know you could
retire from screaming in the basement
remember those people outside the window
banging trying to give someone handled
it so well that nobody knew that the
people that were handing the fake news
trophy that apparently was for me he
says that he's retiring because he
thinks the president Trump's going to be
impeached and his work is done yeah he
lives for humiliating Republicans he
spent the entire Bush term rooting for
President Bush's impeachment and now
he's not gonna dance on Trump's grave
when he's in Peach if he gave I'm not
buying it the guy's talented nice run at
ESPN but it's over and I hope Trump
gives him a little tweet and says
goodbye
do you know Dana that's like me saying
I'm going to retire from needlepoint you
know because I think I think I've done
it it's like he's retiring from
something that nobody really cares about
except for seeing clips of it on this
show never knew that one time he
actually I know that you probably got
this honor too but I was shocked the
time that he declared that I was the
worst person in the world yes I got that
I'd be the worst person Robert Mugabe
I'm the worst person that's pretty
disturbing that's actually a good point
Kimberly because his problem was he
couldn't prioritize you know right or
wrong everything was evil if you just
you disagreed with him you everybody was
evil so you were as bad as Hitler mm-hmm
well I guess we should once again thank
President Trump because he's completely
driven chief over and off the edge and
into retirement so once again making
America great again what yeah
eliminating Oberman you know what I hope
these does he never does this to you I
hope that you don't leave because Trump
drives you crazy
he does drive me crazy I don't this week
he has this trophy you know I didn't
know that they wanted you for the trophy
I was worried I was worried they're
coming after me but I'm saying this fake
news trophy the press is the enemy of
the American people and you guys just
laugh it off oh this is it's Ronnie he
says it's about me me me me me so just
so funny he's just being I don't think
it's funny and I don't think it's funny
when you have project Veritas and James
O'Keefe on the right creating false
sting operation no and when you have
them doing it guess what Trump was a big
dough you gave 10,000 bucks the project
Veritas enoki and when they do this to
Planned Parenthood or a query the right
wing says oh this is great we're going
after the mainstream media when in fact
these guys are the frogs you know what
uh we weren't going to do this segment
but I want to respond to that Joe this
is new for conservatism okay physically
flawed no question but this is new you
guys the left have been doing this for
years you're really good at it you have
Michael Moore winning Academy Awards
from it you have 60 minutes who have
pioneered the art of gotcha journalism
the modern conservatives they're just
getting started wait a minute you say 60
minutes CBS and Michael Moore yes do
phoney sting operation oh no they date
they mastered the art and also consumer
reporters to master the art of sting
reporting they used to show up with a
foot microphone into somebody's family
they don't like Jesse of course asleep
people
I'm not look I'm not defending I'm
telling you is that a big difference
your buns want to tell you is that and
it's relatively new for the right but
the left has been doing the hey beers do
good journalists I have I have a
solution though there needs to be a
rehab
called for Trump broken syndrome like
Gruman that Celebrity Rehab on vh1 Trump
wrote and you could have all these
celebrities of Keith you could have
Kathy Griffin what's-her-face from Will
& Grace Snoop Dogg are you purposely not
know she's a has-been nobody I forgot
what's funny gone I know it's a terrible
what is wrong with you the worst show on
TV hey Greg do you ever think you should
say you know maybe something's off with
Trump's ignoring the t's you know what
everybody has something off about
themselves oh I just happen to be more
forgiving forgiving up truck